[Music]
my name is Alan Bernstein oh no mate
Alan Bernstein I have the distinct honor
and pleasure of being the president and
the CEO of C far good afternoon everyone
Bonjour to them all welcome and thank
you for coming to the annual David dodge
lecture today's lecture is by the
distinguished economist our own Acemoglu
on title AI robotics and the future of
work so if you here for the the other
lecture going on at the Canadian Club
you can get up now and free up a seat I
think there's probably no topic in
science that is as much in the public
eye as artificial intelligence here in
Canada by far the most powerful form AI
and is an entirely made in Canada
discovery geoff hinton from Google in
the University of Toronto Yann laocoon
from NYU and Facebook and yoshua bengio
the université de montréal have worked
together under the auspices of C far of
a CFR program now called learning and
machines and brains and they are the
acknowledged so for fathers or
grandfather's of deep learning deep
learning AI the most powerful form of AI
as I said because of CFR's
I think historic role in the development
of deep learning the budget for this to
the federal budget 2017 included a
hundred and twenty five million dollar
allocation to see far to develop a new
program in in AI designed to position
and strengthen Canada as a global leader
in the science of training in artificial
intelligence and to address the broad
implications of AI for society Daniel
Dennett one of the world's great
philosophers and a seafaring
CFR program called brain mine
in consciousness wrote in about AI and
his new book from bacteria to Bach and
back again and I quote I'm not worried
about humanity creating a race of super
intelligent agents destined to destroy
us but that does not mean I'm not
worried unquote
I you know I have a little game I played
not a day goes by when there isn't a
major article in the media about AI and
so it's sort of an unusual day when AI
is crowded out by Senate testimonies or
something and so and I think it speaks
to the public's great interest in this
topic that I don't think the public is
misplaced in their interest
an AI of course has huge implications
across almost everything or everything
and so where everything includes things
like smart cars banking medicine law
advanced manufacturing disruption of the
labor force and the nature of work
itself certainly over the course of my
own scientific career I think there few
technologies have come along that has
captured the public's attention with the
equivalent disruptive potential as
artificial intelligence that disruption
always comes with significant societal
challenges and opportunities and as part
of our new AI program we are
establishing a new initiative called AI
in society that will bring together some
of the world's leading thinkers in this
area social scientists humanists and
scientists to engage in long term deeply
collaborative discussions with each
other with governments and with civil
society indeed I think today's address
by darrone can be regarded as a launch
of our program in this area see far
senior fellow Daron Acemoglu has been
examining some of these issues and will
be sharing them with us all today but
first let me say a few words about David
dodge actually David is somebody who
truly needs no introduction
especially in this town he is a giant
both little literally and figuratively
and and I think would be redundant for
me to say more about David in Ottawa
this lecture series is named after David
to recognize his enormous legacy of
contributions both the CFR and to the
country and as a supporter and board
member and board chair here at CFR
David's interest in CFR actually I think
began with one of our other programs on
the importance of the early years and
children and now call child and brain
development and I think again it
typifies I think what is really the best
about CFR which is that it brings
together great people from around the
world including Canada to really make
breakthrough knowledge create
breakthrough knowledge around an
important issue and to increase the
impact of that knowledge on society and
so I think it's fair to say that one of
the reasons we have eternity leave in
this country and all-day kindergarten is
because of that early program on the
importance of the early years and
David's own involvement in that program
and was see far more broadly David
remains an active member of Steve FAR's
board and I'm very pleased that he's
here with us today I'd also like to
recognize the other members of CFR's
board who are with us today our chair
Barb's diamonds Pierre ducros Eaton
Morton Friis and McLellan Pat Meredith
Ruth Mitchell and Lawrence Pentland and
I'm blessed with having a fabulous board
some of whom as I said are here with us
today I'd also like to thank Meredith
Hariri the president and CEO of the
Canadian science policy conference our
partner in presenting this lecture today
and finally I'd like to thank the
government of Canada for their ongoing
and long-term support through I said for
seif are represented here today by John
doubly the Deputy Minister and I said we
are very grateful for that support and
through that support for the
government's I think explicit
recognition of the role that global
research plays in addressing the serious
challenges and
opportunities facing our world and by
supporting CFR by truly positioning
Canada as a leader on the world stage
and now it is my distinct pleasure to
introduce Tyrone Acemoglu their own is a
senior fellow in CFR's program and
institutions organizations and growth
she holds the Elizabeth and James
Killian professor of economics at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology he
is the co-author with James Robinson of
the highly influential book Why nations
fail the origins of power prosperity and
poverty he's a fellow of the US National
Academy of Science the American Academy
of Arts and Science and of the American
economic society he is a recipient of
numerous awards that I won't list them
all but I'll just note too one is the
John Bates Clark medal from the American
economics Association a very prestigious
award and he will be receiving one
reason he has to leave right after this
lecture is he has to fly to be grid to
receive the very prestigious BBVA award
in Madrid Spain today he will speak to
us about AI robotics on the future of
work to wrong
[Applause]